Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 27th,
2015 how's it going out?
Yeah,
July.
Where's the fucking summer going kit.
Okay,
Jodie.
You know what I want to get,
I want to get some of that fucking,
how's that politician on the beer?
The Sam Adams Summer Ale kid,
right.
I drank the summer ale in the summer.
Right in the fall.
I drink the one with the fucking cherries in it.
And then the rest of the time I just drink their regular lug.
Yeah.
What's up everybody?
So old Billy red cakes.
Oh,
red velvet here.
He's been trying to lose weight.
[inaudible]
let's go freckles.
You fucking do shit.
Go get a Tan.
No wants to see your fucking pasty legs at the beach.
Um,
so last week I was supposed to be 180 pounds,
but I was not in the fulfillment of a,
of a,
of a scale.
And by the way,
somebody gave me shit like,
dude,
what kind of fucking respectable hotel doesn't have a scale?
It doesn't have a scale where you like that.
That comes standards where you were.
You stay.
Where are you staying at?
Huh?
You staying at the old Illuminati Yen?
Did some broad come in wearing some fucking weird mask?
I'll fucking naked.
One of those fucking perfectly shaped broads like you see in the movie by the
guy who did the eyes wide shut was wandering to Stanley Kubrick.
Stanley Kubrick has some of the hottest broads ever in the history of film in
his movies ever.
Ever.
You know,
it's just a shame.
Horrible Shit happens to them,
but you,
you know,
in the midst of the horror he like got,
damn,
that's a beautiful woman.
Then I think that really speaks to the beauty of a woman.
That's something horror.
Look,
it'd be happening where you're like,
wow,
she looks like a fucking statue with a muff.
All right.
They never have the muffs and statues.
If you noticed that it's a little difficult with the concrete,
what are you going to do?
Huh?
Have somebody with long fingernails kind of come up while this concrete still
wet and just kind of,
Hey,
do one of those right in the old crotch area.
How does that go,
Bill?
It goes,
that's how you do it.
That's how you make it.
You know,
I took a sculpture class just like old Adolf Hitler did Denise or he'd take a
painting class.
I don't know what he did.
And it just always makes me kind of smile thinking there was a point in his life
where he was just thinking he was going to be an artist,
you know,
sitting there with an Easel,
you know what I mean?
Paint some ducks,
you know,
by a pond.
And then who knows?
Maybe a,
somebody Jewish walked by and sneezed and scare the ducks and it just,
he just fucking snapped and just send them,
just set it down a whole lot of rope,
you know?
Does anybody explored that theory?
Oh,
that was offensive to ducks and Jewish people.
this is blog is going to be easy.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm sitting here in my office.
I'm fucking hot as hell.
I got to close the windows on the counter.
I swear a lot.
You know what I mean?
And I would want to offend the people next door.
God knows I could reach out and touch their fucking house.
Free Cha,
reach out and touch my house.
So fucking stupid.
This is such a fucking stupid city I live in is a city,
yet I live in a house in a city,
you know,
and I have a Yad,
but I,
but I don't know what I mean.
Get up the drapes closed people just walking by looking at you and shit.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm back here.
So anyways,
I was supposed to get down to 180 fucking pounds.
I couldn't weigh myself.
Last week I was at the just for laughs festival.
The booze was flowing all right.
And I stayed away.
Okay.
What's that fucking grunts or stay away
was Alison change off a jar?
Flies,
I believe.
Wow.
That takes me back in the day.
Hey,
let's,
let's go down this add fucking stream before I get to my official way.
And,
um,
I used to listen to that fucking
dead fucking cassette tape when I would be driving in my 83 Ford Ranger with the
re rebuilt Ford cylinder.
That the broad I work with told me that was a dumb move.
She was all excited that I was going to buy a new car and my brother told me,
don't do that.
Then you change your day job.
You don't want to fucking do that.
So I didn't,
I rebuilt it.
I didn't rebuild it.
Had somebody else put a brand new one and that's what happened.
The other one fucking burned up.
So I fucking had a brand new one put in,
cost me 1500 bucks at the time.
This is the early nineties.
I still remember that woman when I went to work.
She's like,
where's the new car?
I said,
Oh,
you know what?
I decided to put a new engine in my truck instead.
She just like made this what the fuck?
Look and just wrinkled her nose and went,
that was stupid.
Um,
was it,
was it stupid?
Maybe I don't want to stay at a wearing this smock for the rest of my life.
All right.
With your fucking whatever you got there,
what was it,
the Nissan Power Ranger.
What did they make in the early 80 stare at?
Everybody loved the Maxima.
You get it.
You're taking it to the Max.
To your mom Maxima.
Next of my [inaudible] I can't afford the payments.
Can you take over?
I got fired for smoking weed on the door,
right?
I did a little blow.
Okay.
I stayed out off.
Fuck,
I will.
Um,
that's what you hear in Boston when the windows ain't closed.
So anyways,
uh,
what was I saying?
So I used to fucking drive that thing and um,
oh man,
those are the fucking days.
And I would do fucking Dick Doherty's roam up and drink it.
I do the high five,
this restaurant on top of the only skyscraper and fucking Manchester,
New Hampshire or the other fucking the other town there.
What's the other town?
There's two towns in fucking New Hampshire.
The rest of it is fucking beautiful woods.
Strange's probably a lot of people doing heroin.
Heroin's back in a big way.
Hey,
tell you this kid has been on stage in wells spring up.
Um,
the other one,
Nashua see them,
I think it was in Manchester.
I do the high five.
I used to do Bob,
my fucking roam on old orchard beach.
And I used to fucking listen to that cassette tape over and over and over again
the whole way down.
In fact,
I remember coming back down down one 28 head and back down to my house.
I had to work the next fucking day,
driving like 80 miles an hour.
And then all of a sudden I got a fucking flat Tahlia and I'm pulling over on the
side of the fucking row.
One of the scary seats you can do on the highway pulled over.
And uh,
all they had was that,
you know,
that little fucking,
that awful poor excuse for a fucking tire iron,
you know,
it's just like the little,
uh,
when he cut,
you could fit it right up your sleeve,
a little l shape fucking thing.
And I knew I didn't have enough leverage because I had been there before.
So I always had a section of pipe behind the seat and a dude.
I changed that thing like I don't think a pit crew,
well actually a pit cook would do it,
but for one person I changed that fucking tire so God damn fast and on the side
of the road I had my spare in the back of the truck,
you know that section of pipe fucking four lugs.
I used to have that down.
I had so many fucking flats over the years and that they was such a piece of
shit.
That truck that I had knew the whole fucking routine.
You know,
take out your spare tire,
sticking under the car,
you know,
a little bit in case it comes slamming fucking down and hits the tire and not
your foot,
right.
Loosen all the fucking lugs with your section of pipe on your little fucking l
shape thing before your race,
that fucking truck.
Then you jack it up.
All right,
you take the fucker off,
you stick,
you know,
and I used to put the lugs right in a row.
There was no cell phones.
I didn't have a flashlight.
I had fucking nothing.
I'd line them right up in the back of the truck.
I used to pray to God that had happened on the right side.
Like that was a good night.
And you stick the fucker back on.
You start all four of them.
You set the thing back down and your web,
what Bass,
what bash with passion.
Then you're back in the fucking truck failing.
Like
anyways.
So what was I talking?
I was talking about how I go,
how much weight I lost.
So,
um,
so I was supposed to be at one 80 last week.
Did not have a scale because evidently I stay in shitty hotels and a this week I
was supposed to be one 77.
All right.
And I fucking worked out the whole time I was up in Montreal,
I ran the stairs,
royal park,
whatever the fuck they call it.
Um,
ran those almost every day or as long as I could.
I took one day off and a,
but that day I played hockey and absolutely fucking embarrass myself.
Oh my,
I hadn't played hockey and like four months and I already sucked.
And I went out there and just for laughs,
knew this guy who used to play for the fucking Canadians and he looks like a
fucking movie star.
Come on.
Habs fans,
you know he is,
Huh?
First number four,
second number four later traded to the devils.
He's got this fucking sick ass like little mini rink.
So anyways,
we,
Stefan reshape.
So we fucking shell up and I'm going,
oh my God,
this fucking Stefan Rache he used to kill us.
And um,
so we played in like the other team was just a bunch of ringers and they came
out there and like my first shift,
I think I was on the ice for like fucking three seconds and they scored,
you know,
and I'm coming back and immediately everybody knows.
They already knew I sucked.
But now like they now it's like they have like,
they know how much I suck,
right.
And,
uh,
they,
the other team scored like fucking three goals within.
Um,
okay.
I don't know,
maybe a minute.
And uh,
then all of a sudden we got like two and then blah,
blah,
blah.
Then they were up like eight to five and then dot.
And then people,
you know,
this is basic what happened.
They realized that they will way better and they were nice enough to let us win
by one.
That's what happened.
I think we won like 13 to 12.
Um,
it was a good time.
I had zero shots on net.
Never fell down though.
I know it went down right.
Have enough weed out.
But I was,
I was,
uh,
I was awful.
Oh Man.
I should have skated at least once before I went up there and um,
but whatever,
I burned some calories.
Uh,
but thank you to everybody there at the rink that let us play out there.
I had a great,
despite the fact that I was fucking horrific,
I had a great time and uh,
I don't know,
hockey plays it just fucking funny guys to hang out with.
Anyways,
everybody was busting balls in that type of shit.
And you know,
guys coming into the face off,
I'm going up against all freckles,
you know,
giving me shit.
And then they go right around me and you know what?
There was nothing I could do about it.
So thanks to everybody hooking it up and thank you to the other team for letting
us win by one or two,
whatever you did.
It's very nicely,
very hospitable.
So anyways,
so now I come back
and uh,
I stepped on the scale this morning.
It's Sunday.
I was supposed to be one 80 last week and one 77 this week.
And I got on the scale.
Yeah.
And my weight was 180 pounds even.
So,
so I'm three pounds behind.
What the fuck I wanted to do,
however I was 81 86.6 when I started this fucking thing.
So,
okay.
What does a quitter do?
Huh?
What does a quitter do besides take off her horse shoes and walk barefoot back
to the fucking hotel room across the casino floor with dirty ass fucking feet.
What else does a quitter do?
Acquired.
It goes like,
wow,
I was supposed to be one 77 and I'm one 80 forget it.
Fuck that last week was a wash for me.
All right,
I'll consider that a bye week cause I was on the road.
So next week I got to get down to one 77 who gives a fuck as long as I reach my
goal of getting down to 162 pounds.
The last time I had abs.
All right,
this is my last big push.
I'm turning 50 in three fucking years.
He's my last hope.
Nobody has abs in their 50s unless you did heroin in your 20s and that's a fact.
And you can fucking look it up.
Look at Keith Richards.
So get a fucking shape.
That guy said,
despite his horrific habits,
tremendous shape.
You know all those fucking guys.
Anybody who did the fucking smack.
The key is,
is not to Odi and die.
You get clean and I dunno what it is,
man,
the rest of your fucking life,
just like he just have an orange and like you,
if you're full for fucking 10 hours,
I have no idea how they do it.
Um,
I don't want to sound out and people that did heroin,
well let's just say if you do hard drugs in general,
you know,
look at what's his face there from that band,
that had the puppets on the cover.
You know what I'm talking about?
Ah,
yams get him
right.
He's fucking skinny as shit and he's pushing 60,
uh,
I'm not advocating doing heroin.
I'm just talking about having an abs in your 50s.
I'm doing it.
Oh.
Naturale so no heroin.
Um,
so anyways,
I feel though I do feel by tomorrow Monday,
which you listen to now,
not to fuck you up.
I will be one 79,
so I'm only like two pounds behind.
Um,
so when I keep doing it as I keep switching up the fucking workout and uh,
Bert fucking Kreischer was nice enough to send me something about grip strength,
but one of those men's magazines that,
um,
I can never commit to having a subscription to cause it's just the same thing
over.
And like all those men's health magazines,
you know what?
They're just like cosmo.
If you really look at the covers,
it's the same shit every,
every fucking episode or whatever you call every issue.
COSMO's always some fucking hot fucking air brush broad,
right?
There's something else,
you know,
so and so's most in depth a fucking interview ever.
She's finally found happiness,
right?
Or whatever.
And then there's always,
you know,
either how to get your man,
how do you know if your man's fucking around how to really please you man,
how to get your man to please you one on one of those fucking articles.
And then on the men's one,
all right,
they always got some guy who's kind of famous,
right?
Who shredded airbrushed and all of that shit.
And it's always hard to get abs and fucking 20 days,
uh,
the Cirque de Solei Diet or some fuck some fucking diet.
And then,
oh,
some new new new fucking arm workout that's going to explode your biceps
assumption.
It's all the same fucking crap.
You know what you gotta do?
All right?
You fucking eat.
Eat.
Well,
the beginning of the day,
you have your fruits before fucking 12,
and then after that you go Veggie,
you have your fucking meat that the size of the palm behavior even remotely near
that.
And you're working out.
If you're doing half hour of fucking cardio and you lay off the booze,
the ice cream,
the chips,
the cookies and all that shit,
where is it going to get a fence?
Got Nowhere to hide it turned the lights on,
the roaches all fucking starts scurrying.
Did I?
That's the first time ever you scurrying at fucking eight years of doing a
podcast.
You know what you gotta do?
You don't need those fucking magazines,
but every once in a while you get bored with your workout.
You want something new.
So Bert Kreischer sent me this thing.
I'm going to go back on my Twitter history and try and find it.
But he sent me this killer fucking um,
grip strength workout.
And uh,
one of the first thing is you just try to hang from a chin up bar in the pullup
position for fucking a minute,
three sets of one minute.
And um,
the key to that is just hang there.
What I was doing was I was kind of in like a,
like a fucking the first third of a pull up so I was burning out.
But if you just hang it,
it's not that fucking hard.
So now I've moved to the next one,
which is you,
you do it again for a minute,
but you hang in there holding the bar with one hand and the other one you drape
some sort of cloth,
you know,
whatever.
If you're in your garage like me,
the fucking rag,
he used to fucking check your oil,
which is probably stupid cause there's oil on it,
whatever.
That helps with the grip strength and that one you hold,
you just drape it over.
Just some sort of face cloth.
You drape that over and you're hanging onto that with one hand,
the other hands on the bar,
you try to do it for a minute and then you switch hands.
And,
uh,
I've been able to do it for a minute on one side and then the other side,
I did it for about 45 seconds.
That's where I'm at on that thing.
And then of course,
you're like,
well,
let me put two up there and see if I can just hang by two fucking rags.
And I almost broke both my knee caps.
That's hard as shit for me anyways,
you know,
so that's what the fuck I'm at.
So I'm going to get down to one 77 next week by hook or by Crook and I'm,
I'm hanging in there with the boosts 21 days,
no booze.
I'm getting to the point of,
hey,
you know,
it gives a fuck.
I was kidding.
No,
I can't wait for September 15th.
September.
It was September 16th is when I can boost.
That's when I can,
uh,
I can booze again.
But,
uh,
I got to tell you,
um,
the hardest place for me to not booze actually is my house.
You know why?
Cause I got the good shit.
You know,
you go into a fucking bar.
What am I going to do out there?
I'm married so I don't give a shit about the women out there,
you know?
And then I got to spend 10 times,
what am I going to pay at home and I'm going to drink,
eat fucking cheap boots,
right?
Why the fuck would I do that?
In fact,
all you youngsters out,
I know,
cause you give you a union what?
You're single,
you want to get laid or whatever.
But if you really want to go out for a fucking night of drinking,
you want some good.
It's just like eating at home.
It's way cheaper.
Pull your fucking money together.
All he is and how many attacks.
Don't get yourself just a fucking bottle of Johnnie Walker blue.
Just get that.
You know what I mean?
Don't put any ice on it.
You can't sip it like a fucking gentleman telling you.
I don't know that.
You know who the Yuki can appreciate that in your 20s,
if you appreciate that in your 20s,
uh,
you're,
you're a fucking raging alcoholic.
If your palate is that sophisticated,
either that or you have dad's a banker,
Assam Shit,
you know,
instead of you finishing his morning coffee with some sort of booze so we can
numb the fucking lies he was going to tell all day out.
Jesus,
Bill,
could you get more dramatic?
I'm sorry.
What?
What do you want from me?
We Times I've got to tell you guys,
I've got an hour to fucking fill here.
I would have fucking fill over there.
Um,
all right,
let's get to some of the reads for this week.
Hey everybody,
you're going to get the listen to me.
Read out loud.
Um,
by the way,
um,
no,
uh,
no hard feelings with a,
a draft kings by the way.
They explained that position to me.
They,
they know that the gambling,
they don't give a fuck,
right?
But they're just a business with baseball.
They're trying to make their money.
Why would I be a Douche and try to part them for making money?
Right.
So they said eventually they'll come back to the podcast and I'll play ball.
All right,
I'll play ball.
What do you want from me?
You know,
I immediately,
it was probably because I never talked to the advertisers.
That helps,
you know whenever they call it the complaint.
Is he available?
No.
When is he available?
Never.
I already know what you're gonna say.
Ooh.
Like what you said.
All right,
darling.
Shave club everybody.
For only a dollar you can get a great shave.
Alrighty.
I've got to tell you.
Shaving the old way sucks a lot.
It hurts.
You lather up with cheap foam wincing.
His hair is scraped from your face.
With those old worn out razors,
you won't throw away.
Why?
Because they cost so God damn much.
Well,
not anymore.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club sends amazing razors for a few bucks and when you
use them with their members only what the jacket with their members only owe Dr
Covey's EEZ shea.
Okay.
Completely changed.
It changes the game.
Forget foam.
The foam face.
This stuff is the real deal.
It's magic.
Something happens when you put it on.
It's hard to describe it,
but it feels amazing.
It's the most gentle,
peaceful shave imaginable.
It's just starting to make me think about Hitler with that Easel.
Painting the ducks.
You barely know your shaving.
Never a good thing to bring up.
Hitler in the middle of it.
Add other shaving products can leave your face feeling dry and tight.
It's awful.
But Dr Covey's easy shave fucking butter is high quality stuff.
Just like their razors.
It's got organic.
All natural ingredients like pear cactus and black willow bark.
Ah,
so you know,
it's good.
So your skin feels fresh,
smooth and moisturized after a shape.
How the fuck does bark make your face smooth?
It's gotta be the shit in it,
right?
They wring it out.
You know there's grip strength for you,
Huh?
Wringing out some fucking tree bark.
It's great to,
if you have sensitive skin,
Dr Carver's easy shave butter from dollar shave club is like nothing.
You've tried Dr Carver's.
Easy shave bothered.
Just one more reason to try dollar shave club.
Do it today@dotdollarshaveclub.com slash bird that's dollar shave club.com/burr
oh shit.
Here we go.
The classic Mandy's me undies.
No more sweaty balls,
but due to to me undies Biondi is by a whole bunch for the fall.
You will be freezing your fucking balls off.
You got your two balls wrapped up in a sock.
[inaudible] shape like some fucking shorts.
They make you balls.
Feel real nice like Chinchilla.
Go get yourself some me undies and floss your crotch.
Me undies.com is committed to making the world's most comfortable underwear.
They fit perfectly.
Keep your cool and a made from Madell.
Gotta go to Moe's.
I don't know what that shit is,
which is a sustainably sourced from beechwood trees in Austria speaking to
Hitler.
That's the first one.
He took two for two on the advertising with the old Hitler reference resulting
in a fabric that is two times softer than cotton and now my podcast,
or they are,
I don't know who's we're offering 20% off your first order when you go to
[inaudible] me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
meundies.com/ [inaudible] if you don't love them,
your first pair is free.
Again,
that's 20% off your first order.
The world's best underwear at m,
e n d u,
N D,
I e s.com/burr.
Get yourself a pair and your balls.
We'll be out without a care.
All right,
now where do we go from here?
How many have we got?
We got two for this week.
All right,
well we got five.
we'll do three and two.
Three,
two.
All right,
Uber.
Okay.
Hey,
you like making great money,
right?
You don't,
well then don't listen to the rest of this,
but if you like making money,
do you want to get out there?
Here's a real cool opportunity that,
uh,
Uber had to share with you driving with Uber.
Uber's that popular smart phone app that connects riders with drivers.
Okay?
If you take Uber a bunch,
why don't you become an Uber driver if you love them?
If you like chatting with the different drivers,
you know,
and listening to their interesting stories,
you could be one of them,
you know?
Do you ever notice those Uber drivers,
they
love being their own bosses.
They are great money and it's easy to start.
All you need is a car and a license.
Driving with Uber is great for anyone who needs flexibility.
Parents,
there's this,
uh,
this is a really great,
really easy way to work around your family schedule.
It's a great way to avoid your family.
You know what I mean?
It's a great way to do a whole bunch of things.
You know what?
That's a great job for a hitman.
I'm going to go make some extra money,
honey.
See you later.
Go Up.
You know,
you pick a couple of fairs,
you go make your hit and then you come back,
right?
It's all kind of,
the opportunities are endless.
With Uber Students,
you can make extra money between classes.
No more strip in lay.
Now's the prime time to cash in with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling you how to get paid every week.
All right,
call to action.
here's the series part.
You got a car and a license put on bolts to work your scumbag.
Why you a scumbag?
Put 'em both foot cause I was talking like that.
Slow down.
Don't put them both for work for you and start earning serious life.
Changing money.
Sign up to Uber.
Uber.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com.
That's drive with U B E r.com.
Drive with uber.com.
I was like,
I won the first three quarters and I fucked it up in the end.
Christ,
you're lost the game.
Um,
anyway,
so let's,
uh,
let's move on with the podcast here.
A lot of shit happened in the news.
The latest person to get in trouble and to be branded a racist mania.
How Cogan it's running wild.
Um,
the holster,
having a conversation,
dropping the n word,
dropping the fucking end.
So then his brought his,
his uh,
his daughter comes to his defense,
says he's not a racist.
You know,
I don't know who the fuck,
what are you going to do?
I mean,
you're dropping the n word that,
that's a rough one.
I'll tell you,
You know,
then he's got friends who are African kid in America yet he's fucking dropping
the n word.
You know what I think it really is.
I think there's a bunch of different levels to being racist.
You know what I mean?
It's like me,
I play drums,
but it's just a fucking hobby.
John Bonham was a fucking drum,
you know what I mean?
So like the John Bonham's of,
of,
of racism are like in the clan there in like those white supremacy groups,
you know,
they were in the,
the fucking Dwayne,
it will be with the Nazis.
You know what I mean?
They are professional fucking racist.
This is what they do.
This is how they are to living.
You know,
can you earn a living in the claim?
Is it a kind of like a volunteer fire department,
but you,
but you're just fucking,
you're racist and you start fires would,
it's like a drum circle except you just say hateful shit.
Okay,
what exactly is the client?
Why would you join Klan?
And then he got other people who are more like,
you know,
it's like they're not a professional racist,
but if they wanted to be,
they wanted to be,
they could be the grand dragon in the clan.
They just don't apply themselves.
So instead they work at like home depot or some shit.
Right.
They think just as much fucked up shit.
And then he got the person who occasionally,
you know,
like me goes around plays drums every once in a while.
These guys do the same thing except they drop the n word every once in a while.
I think Hogan is like right around there,
you know what I mean?
Just like when his daughters saying he's not a racist,
she means like he's not in the clan,
he doesn't have a swastika tattoo.
You know what I mean?
But he's still playing drums there.
You know what I'm saying?
Why am I relating drums to fucking be in rice?
I don't fucking know.
Who knows?
He was also,
I looked up his age.
He's 61 years old.
He was born August 11th,
1953 so that means if his parents,
Adam,
it like what?
Like 25
they were born in 1928 so Jesus Christ,
I mean what the fuck we are his parents filling his heads head up with,
right.
His parents lived through the depression.
They was already preaching that there wasn't enough and that black people,
now that they were free,
we're going to take everything from the white man.
That paranoia was probably already there.
Then they went into the fucking depression.
So maybe his parents were extra fucking racist.
So we had to crawl out of that hole and him crawling out of that hole was having
black friends.
But Eh,
but you know,
he's like one of those,
he has black friends,
but he's like,
I don't want my daughter to date one.
So he's like,
you know,
I tell you,
he was like an intermediate racist.
I don't know what to tell you.
I don't know what to tell your brother.
Um,
what are you going to do?
Who's getting,
no,
you know you're fucking,
you put a tape recorder on and people still don't know the song.
Who knows what the fuck and,
but we would all have to apologize for something if somebody left a fucking tape
recorder on all God Damn Day long and you didn't know was on Nixon lost the
White House doing that shit.
You wouldn't be in trouble.
Jesus Christ,
the fucking Shit that I say over the course of a day of,
of fucking broads and all this tie that something,
something would come out,
you know,
have they read all the texts that you do joking around with your friends,
but you know,
it's a fucking joke.
You know what I mean?
Am I say you drop the n word but come on,
somebody would get you,
somebody get you for something homophobic,
right.
Something I don't fucking know.
But uh,
okay.
I think it's,
it's going to be a good thing.
I think the guy,
hopefully we'll learn something from it and he won't do shit like that anymore.
Hopefully you'll know that it's wrong.
But I really think in moments like that,
you gotta let somebody be a fucking human being.
You got to take into consideration when they were born,
what was fed into their fucking heads and give them an opportunity to redeem
themselves.
Cause if you just fuck each,
cancel all his fucking matches and all that,
what is that going to do?
Except drive them more towards anger?
That's what I say.
Cause the other shit's not working.
Firing people.
You know what I mean?
That fucking chef there that had the slave theme fucking wedding.
Do you,
do you think she's not thinking,
you know,
I'm sure she's a little bit better,
but did that really help?
I don't fucking know.
What am I talking about?
Who knows?
So,
uh,
let's get back to the podcast.
So I,
oh,
he all,
this is what I wanted to talk about.
Here we go.
So Tom Bray slaying all the ladies.
Um,
he's,
you know,
he appealed the four game suspension and I'm somebody who is speaking for all
the owners said that they were,
they were all hoping that they would all the other arms.
I should say,
we're hoping that uh,
the NFL would uphold this suspension
because what he did was so fucking horrific or allegedly did,
you know,
they can't fucking prove it or whatever.
That's the thing.
They can't fucking prove he did anything yet.
There's a four game fucking suspension that these cops want to be upheld that
they want to have upheld and the number one and two people fucking that are on
their side,
believe it or not,
are the Indianapolis Colts and the fucking Baltimore Ravens.
And this is such a fucking lay up for a joke.
The Ravens fucking quote,
let me find it here.
Okay.
Was that the Patriots have been getting away with murder for years.
Why?
If you're connected with the Baltimore Ravens,
would you ever use the expression getting away with murder?
These fucking teams,
you know,
they're all sitting in glass houses and I love that they fucking trash the
Patriots for whatever the fuck it is.
They think that we're doing.
You know,
like they're these holier than thou people.
You want to talk about getting away with murder.
Hey,
how about this?
At least when one of our players is involved in a murder,
the fucker goes to jail,
you know at least we got that on you,
the fucking ravens.
Jesus Christ and your last fucking decade.
Yeah,
the guy fucking
fucking drop his fiance and an elevator and drag her out.
And you guys were fine with the four game suspension cause all you give a fuck
about is the performance and then you add on to your other guy there,
right.
Okay.
Obstruction of justice in a double fucking homicide.
Not only do you look the other fucking way,
you let him play in the Superbowl,
he invites his two buddies there who are up on the fucking double homicide
charges are sitting there in the game and you didn't give a fuck and you're
going to talk about,
okay,
shame on you.
Shame on you Baltimore Ravens and know you have to get involved with the
Indianapolis Colts.
Every game that Andrew luck starts is cheating for the Indianapolis Colts.
Considering how they got him and they tanked and entire fucking season.
And if you don't think that they did that,
then you still believe in Santa Claus.
All right?
I'm not even saying my team is fucking it.
Innocent.
Not by any stretch of the fucking means.
I don't give a fuck if you say my team cheats,
but it's when you get on your high horse and you say that your team doesn't
cheat too.
That's when I say,
Hey,
you know what?
I think I'm going to walk away from this and I'm going to go have myself a water
with the lemon because I'm on the wagon.
Yeah.
One of the fucking ravens in the cults just own up to the fact that you're just
jealous of how long the patriots have been good and how many fucking Superbowls
we've been to when,
how many gains we fucking won.
All right.
You cuts,
you got yourself two super bowls.
The Ravens.
What's your fucking problem?
Indianapolis.
I know what that guy's fucking problem is.
It's his goddamn personal life.
Um,
oh Geez.
Oh,
I was a low blow.
I did not want to say that.
I didn't want to say that,
but I'm just sick of this guy trying to fucking,
you know,
of course,
these constant want Brady to come back.
They want the Patriots to be Oh and forced.
So they got a fucking chance at winning a better fucking chance right now.
Do you think they're really outraged at the Patriots?
They're not.
This is just part of them.
The same way,
like you fucking tank a season to get Andrew luck the same way you look the
other way and obstruction of justice or a fucking,
you know,
somebody's beating the shit out of somebody in an elevator because you want
those players on the fucking field.
You don't want Brady on the field.
So of course you're going to play the outrage card.
Of course you're going to do that when someone else almost beat the fucking
girlfriend to death and almost got fucking four games.
Not Talking about the guy from Baltimore,
this latest fucking guy.
All right?
It's complete fucking horseshit.
So anybody out there who's actually buying into this shit,
yeah,
you're just a Patriot hater,
or you believe in Santa Claus.
All right.
And I'm never going to hear your argument because I don't go to sports bars.
I think people who actually really think that this is a big deal,
the whole fucking deflate gate thing or the kind of people that even in July are
sitting there wearing a pro level Nfl Jersey with somebody else's name on the
back and you got wing sauce and you in your fucking beard stubble.
All right?
And you ought to be ashamed of yourself.
I think it's high time you fucking grow up.
What do you think about that?
I don't give a fuck if Brady comes back in game six.
We're still gonna make the playoffs and we still going to come back and fucking
hunt.
You counts.
Right?
And we're going to break your hearts and your own fucking stadium.
I don't care how loud you are.
All right.
Well if you go there dressed like a bird,
you know,
oh,
you got a sword in your tooth a year.
Fucking eat a dog bone.
They don't give a fuck they're,
they're going to come in there and metaphorically speaking,
they're going to gut you.
All right.
So get ready for the heartache.
Another football season's coming.
Oh,
talking to a bunch of shit.
I don't give a fuck.
We just want a fourth.
I'm a happy thin.
Um,
speaking of which,
being up in Montreal,
um,
always makes me think of the expos.
And,
uh,
I would tell you that time I went to an expose game by myself.
I was doing a Gig.
Okay.
I might've done it.
It was either a college or I did the Lake Ontario playhouse.
Um,
way back in the day.
that's like one of the first headlining lining gigs I got outside of the New
England area.
And uh,
Mike Kenny I believe was the guy who booked me up there,
had a great,
I always love doing that Gig.
But anyways,
um,
so I was up there up on Lake Ontario and it was at that point I was trying to go
to all the ballparks.
So I saw that the expos
had a game the next day.
So I said,
fuck it.
So I got in my rental car by myself and I'm crossing the Canadian border in a
very obscure place.
I'm not coming up 95 and I'm by myself.
So the fucking security guard up there,
you know,
security guard,
you go into another country tunchy five the security guard cause walking up,
he's like a,
he's like,
oh well you're going there.
Hey.
And I was sorry.
And I was like,
I'm going to weigh a nexspos gang.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
you're going up there by yourself.
And I was like,
Yep.
And he goes,
okay,
why don't you pull over there?
Hey.
So I pull over my rental car and I'm like,
what the fuck?
I never got pulled over before.
And I'm standing there and him and this other guy proceeded to rip my fucking
rental car part.
I'm like,
what are they doing?
And then it finally dawned on me
how put that,
they thought
that nobody was pathetic enough to drive an extra two and a half hours to go see
an afternoon expos game by themselves.
Nobody was that sad of a human being.
And it just struck me as funny and I started fucking laughing and they will
looking over at me and I had this big smile on my face and I was laughing cause
I knew they thought this guy has got gotta be dealing drugs,
there's no way he's actually going to an expo as gay by himself.
And um,
it pissed them off and they searched even harder.
And then when did they just realized I was just laughing at them?
Uh,
I think they took extra time almost trying to make me lose the game,
losing I miss the game.
So I end up getting the car and I drove up there and I sat out in the outfield
at Olympic Stadium and I remember they had one arm rest on the chairs out there
and for whatever fucking reason,
bare bones,
it's an Olympic fucking stadium.
It's the one that I believe Bruce Jenner,
who's now Katie,
Caitlin,
right?
He fucking won the,
uh,
the goddamn decathlon there.
And,
uh,
I sat out there and I watched somebody home plate and I jumped up and he fucking
air freaking out that I saw somebody steal home plate.
Yeah.
Um,
then nobody in the stadium was reacting.
So I sat back down thinking I didn't see what I just saw.
And then I went home and I watched TSN or whatever.
Fuck I watched that night.
Uh,
that's their ESPN up there.
And they go,
I have up,
you don't see it.
I love that.
Okay.
And I realized that I had actually seen it and was fucked out of the moment
because the people out in the outfield with too busy singing that soccer song,
that Olay or Layla Layla Bullshit.
Um,
my Montreal story.
So anyways,
uh,
which always reminds me whenever I think of the Expos is,
that fucking team that could have been,
which was the 1994 Montreal Expos,
the one that Pedro Martinez always gets that look in his eye when he talks about
going,
aw man,
we will load it.
We will load it.
They were like the best team in baseball.
And then the strike came canceled the rest of the season and the world series.
And I always thought that Pedro Martinez was on that team with Randy Johnson.
And I believe I've said that on the podcast.
And no one to my knowledge has ever corrected me.
Um,
he wasn't Randy Johnson,
um,
Pedro Martinez was,
was,
was part of one of the worst trades of all fucking time.
The Dodgers thought he was too brittle to small to last and they traded him to
Montreal for fucking Jack Squat.
And um,
so that,
that trade is always brought up.
But the Randy Johnson trade the expos trade to Seattle whenever they do like
that,
some,
you know,
the top 20 worst major league fucking trades of all time,
it's never in there.
So here's one for you.
Here's an obscure one cause people always bring up,
you know,
obviously the biggest one of all time is the Red Sox,
selling Babe Ruth,
you know,
we traded the guy for cash so this guy could fucking
good bankroll his wife's Broadway play.
Unfucking believable.
Unfucking believable,
even unforgivable back then because who knew what it was going to become?
Baseball and everything,
but just fuck it.
That that is the worst one of all time.
But he is one that it is and this fascinates me.
Worst trades of all time that nobody brings that nobody really brings up.
If you guys like to tweet me some,
I'll read,
read some on Thursday.
Um,
or if you want to email me,
I'll,
I'll get the thing here.
What is it?
Uh,
the email is the fuck is it bill@themmpodcast.com.
bill@themmpodcast.com.
So Expos traded Randy Johnson,
he played for them in 1988 and looked promising.
And then he started off 1989 really poorly.
He went,
he started off all in for,
and his era was a little bit high and they just,
I don't know,
they must've thought he was a flash in the pan.
So listen to this.
When the Marin is traded in,
Marin is traded.
Oh,
let let,
I should say the expos traded Randy Johnson to the mariners for Mark Langston
and Mike Campbell.
All right.
And the Seattle got Randy Johnson and then Jean Harris.
Brian Hollman.
Uh,
I believe that that was the trade and virtually all these Seattle players were
unhappy.
Here's some of the homes here,
some of the quotes,
third Baseman,
Jim Presley said.
So this is actually,
I guess exonerates them the,
the expos because if a other pro baseball players will like what the fuck did we
do?
I guess it's not that bad,
but third baseman,
Jim Presley said this is a sad day for Marin,
a baseball in four months.
Now we've lost two of the best pitchers in Marin has history.
Uh,
cause they just trade Langston and Mike Moore who signed with Oakland and the
other side is a free agent and he's going,
yeah,
this is a sad day.
I don't know what went on whether they made him an offer or to him or whether he
wanted Outta here,
but maybe they should have been thinking of how we're supposed to replace them.
Second Basement,
Harold Reynolds,
who's one of my favorite baseball people of all time.
He just knows so much.
He,
this is him as a young man,
said this crushes me and the reality of it all won't hit me until we take the
field tomorrow in Milwaukee.
And Mike Langston won't be there.
Uh,
in defense of him,
that kind of seems like he was buddies with them,
but a catcher day valley just said,
oh no.
Oh No.
Which brings me now to my own Boston Bruins and we had made some very,
to put it mildly aggressive fucking moves here in the off season.
Um,
we obviously traded Milan Lou Cheech to the Cha,
the Kings in exchange in exchange for the 13th overall pick and backup
goaltender Martin Jones and defenseman prospect call and Miller.
Now I really hope in the future as I read these names that the,
some,
some somebody pan the fuck out.
I'm so here.
Okay.
With the flurry of trades and draft picks,
Bruins,
GM,
dawn Sweeney began a roster makeover.
He really did.
So here's what we ended up getting.
We try.
We also traded,
obviously we got rid of Doug Hamilton.
So here,
here's what we got with our picks and I'm hoping someday in the future and the
fucking future,
somebody's going to listen to this and say that this was a great move because,
um,
okay.
You know,
back in the day when we traded a,
what's his face?
I always forget his fucking name.
The hell's his goddamn name.
The guy that we traded,
it wouldn't go into the corners,
but he's Scholes scored all the goals.
We traded them to Toronto.
The only guy I've seen in the NHL,
he,
he looks,
he has like a pickup hockey face.
He looks like he's accountant during the week.
You know what I mean?
He's the only guy I've seen with a fat face.
How are you fat playing hockey?
That's one thing I tell you.
There's no fat fucking hockey players.
Yeah.
Not none whatsoever,
but somehow this guy is fucking fat.
Jesus Christ.
Hang on a second.
What the fuck is this?
God damn name.
Let me look this up here.
Douggie Hamilton,
Hamilton fucking tray.
There we go.
Bruins hurt themselves.
Bruins Trade Douggie Hamilton for draft picks to the fucking fives.
Jesus Christ,
whatever.
So anyways,
what is the guy's name?
I'm sorry.
Everybody right now is fill castle.
All right,
so back in the day we trade Phil Kessel to the Toronto Maple leafs in 2009 for a
pair of first round draft picks that later we'd later use to select Tyler Sagan
and Douggie Hamilton.
And it was expected,
coined this article that those two players would be cornerstones of the
organization,
at least for the next decade.
And by the way,
we ended up winning the Stanley Cup with those two guys.
So now we're doing it again.
We're trading again.
We're kinda like the mini Blackhawks.
We don't win as many.
We've only made,
we've made big fucking moves,
but we've only won one.
So I'm,
I'm actually willing to give Sweeney the benefit of the doubt.
What goes,
who's getting,
no,
this is all I fucking got.
What else am I going to do?
Um,
so here's,
here's all the draft picks that we got.
First round draft pick number 13,
the Boston Bruins,
select defensemen.
I can't even say the guy's name.
Jacob's a board is a Boral 18 was third among rookie defenseman Quebec.
I don't give a fuck how big he is.
He 13 goals.
20th assists last season.
Then we picked this kid number 14 we had backed it back,
picks.
We picked a fucking sniper.
Jake Debraski,
18 six feet tall,
174 pounds.
Jesus Christ,
I'd love to be 174 puffs.
Sorry.
Forward led the Western hockey league.
Swift League.
Swift current in scoring with 42 goals in 39 assists.
Nice and even spreading it around.
Stick it in the back of the fucking net.
Number 15 we selected.
This is the guy I like just just as far as side Zachary Senni Shin.
I don't want to say it's fucking names.
[inaudible] 18th spent last season a Blahblahblahblahblah.
When I,
wait a minute,
where's the fucking,
there's somebody here is like six five Harry is,
this is a guy I got hope for.
Number 37 defensemen.
Brandon Carlo 18 the six 596 found nine at 996 pound defenseman had four goals.
21 assists.
Sounds like he's a stay at home guy,
you know,
I don't know.
I'm hoping somebody pans out.
That's what we got.
So I'm actually kind of excited now.
We're really young.
Fuck it.
Sweeney cleaned house.
What am I going to do?
Be that guy.
Oh Bitch.
Moans and complains.
So hopefully some of those means somebody something to somebody some day.
Right.
And you guys can actually laugh that I mispronounced all of the fucking names.
You know,
hopefully I just mispronounced the next fucking Wayne Gretzky.
Um,
yeah.
But anyways,
it's going to be hard.
It's going to be hard seeing that fucking no Lou cheats.
No.
Douggie Hamilton.
Doug Hamilton was in the prime is fucking career.
I still think that was a fucking crazy move.
Why do you do that?
Sky's a proven guy.
Well,
you know,
he's probably going to want a lot of money while he fucking deserves it.
Pay Him.
All right,
I'm done.
I'm done with that shit.
Let's get back to the fucking podcast here.
Let's get to some of the questions here.
All right.
Uh,
okay.
Romanian fan.
Funny you should say that.
Ashley was actually talking to my agent today about,
uh,
doing an eastern European tour.
I was thinking of doing two European tours next year where I do the,
uh,
the usual guys,
Iceland over to England.
And then next and then later I do fucking Scandinavia and then down the fucking
a Baltic states there.
Um,
hi bill.
My name is Eddie.
I'm a 30 year old Romanian living in the UK.
I'm six one and used to be 290 pounds and in January decided to become serious
and lose weight.
Uh,
I got to a lowest of two 17,
but two months ago I started working as a truck driver and I'm starting to gain
the weight back.
I used a,
I used to work in a warehouse,
very physical job and also quit smoking four months ago.
I listened to your podcast.
I'm a big fan.
Uh,
you are a great comedian and I only wrote to you because I absolutely love your
way and share all your political views.
Please put some punctuation in this.
I know you mentioned my country a few podcasts ago when you were in Paris and
your lovely wife,
who am I salute kindly.
I love people learning English.
It's so proper.
I salute kindly.
Why salute you to kindly and I want you to know that we Romanians are damned to
be born in the same country with those pests that are called Gypsies.
They ruined our name and country,
but I 100% agree with the fact that you did a heads up for your future holiday
makers in Paris.
And second of all,
I'm a trucker and a few podcasts ago you were wondering if truckers are
listening to you.
Uh,
well my good man,
at least one surely does.
The point of the email is do I continue to do this job that I fucking love being
a trucker but probably going to gone
fuck all my hard work,
hard work of losing weight or do you have a piece of advice?
Thank you so very much.
Yeah,
dude,
start eating healthy.
Starting healthy.
What I would do is I would go to the grocery store,
I'd have a fucking cooler and uh,
for breakfast have like an apple or an orange.
I would make sure that I eat really light and at night I would try to get on the
fucking treadmill,
but you have to eat perfectly.
And,
um,
you have to learn way more about nutrition than I do.
But if you love being a truck,
a man just
okay,
you gotta you gotta have a job you love because then it doesn't feel like work.
But if you starting to put the weight on,
um,
okay.
You know,
I would definitely say don't eat after five and I would have a giant fucking
salad with some protein every night for dinner.
Get yourself a sandwich.
I crushed the fucking waters,
you know?
Um,
late night snack,
I do the salary with a spoonful of peanut butter and that gets me through.
And I've never tried to be a trucker that is fucking brutal.
The closest thing I've ever been to a trucker as far as is,
um,
difficult to,
to,
to stay in shape was sitting in a writers room when I sat in the writer's room
at f is for family.
I put on some weight then that went into the holidays,
which went into the world tour,
not world tour.
I want to see on the other side of the world.
And then,
uh,
you know,
these bus tours having fucking help.
So,
um,
okay.
Oh,
and I would do is I just get on the scale,
see what your way,
and then next week tried to just weight lighter.
That's it.
Even if it's just a pound because you can't fucking work out as much.
I would definitely try to be as active as you possibly can.
You know what I would do?
I come up,
this is what I do.
If I was you,
I'd come up with the fucking truck or workout and diet,
you know,
write a book,
figure out what works for you,
then turn it into a goddamn book and then they'll expand it.
Not just the trucker diet.
Just say,
hey,
this worked for a guy driving a truck.
Imagine what it would do for you.
All you do is commute.
They,
they'd sell the shit out of it and then maybe you've got enough money to buy
your own truck and start your own trucking company.
Who knows?
I'll tell you right now,
you have a hit book.
Even after they'd done stealing from you,
at least have time to go to the gym.
All right,
well,
thank you for listening.
And,
uh,
um,
I dunno,
I'll go to Romania someday with my pocket zips.
Shut a girlfriend's parents.
Hey Bill.
I am an eighth grade and I am about to date this girl who is a freshman in high
school.
Dude,
you're fucking crushing it.
And unless you're a woman,
then hey,
go easy.
Yes,
there is a double standard.
Your mother would say the same thing.
Uh,
the only problem is that our parents don't want her to date me because they
think she'll get bullied for dating a person in a lower grade from her.
Oh,
all right.
Okay.
That's interesting.
Uh,
I definitely don't want to leave the relationship for some bullshit reasons.
So I'm asking you and hopefully the lovely Nia to,
for your guys,
advice on what I should do.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Wait,
the only problem is her parents don't want her to date me.
Well,
I mean,
you really don't have a choice here.
you,
your only choices.
I want to keep dating you.
[inaudible] this is the ball is in her court,
is not in her court.
So I would just say her,
say,
listen,
I really like you and I wanna uh,
I wanna be with you.
I'd like to date you.
Okay.
Um,
if you feel the same way,
I'd hope you'd,
you'd want to keep dating me,
but,
uh,
I can't make you date me.
So,
uh,
you know,
that's it.
I'm going all in world series of poker.
I pushed all my chips in.
You still want to be with me.
I'll be down the fucking arcade tonight at eight o'clock.
Whatever the kids do nowadays,
I'll be staring like a Zombie at my fucking playstation flatscreen and the
surround sound.
Um,
I dunno.
What do you,
I don't know what,
what,
what?
What more can you do other than tell her that you want to be with her?
You know,
that's what I would do,
but hey,
no matter what,
end on a good fucking note,
if she can't do it,
just just to play this cart at your fucking age,
just be like,
you know what?
I understand he might even add this in there.
Listen,
I understand.
I don't want to put you in a bad position with your parents,
but I do really like you and I would like to still be with you and that isn't
bullshit,
right?
But the parent part is setting you up for the future because next year you're
going to be a freshman,
provided you study and don't fuck up and be held back.
All right?
Don't be that guy with the mustache in eighth grade,
please.
All right?
And you get to fucking high school.
Now you were in high school.
You know,
it's not as bad.
Sophomore,
freshman who gives it,
nobody's going to give a fuck.
You going to the same school.
You're laying the groundwork to still be in the ball game.
You know what I mean?
You're at bat right now.
The emergency swing right now.
Stay alive.
That's what I would say.
Stay alive in the batter's box.
Just say,
listen,
I know it's gotta be tough that your parents are giving you a rough time.
Okay.
And ultimately the decision's going to be yours,
but I still want to date you because I really like you.
All right?
But,
uh,
I don't want to make you miserable either.
So make you know.
No,
goddammit.
I want one sentence too far to say.
Make a decision that you're comfortable with.
I'll say that.
Say what the fuck I just said and leave off that last thing.
All right.
And then that's it.
And if she fucking lets you go,
like I say,
stay on good fucking terms.
Uh,
with her.
Do not stalk her on Facebook.
Do not pay attention.
If she starts dating somebody else.
Listen,
if she decides to walk,
he just said,
it'd be like,
all right,
well,
maybe next year when I'm in high school.
All right.
Maybe then,
and she'll say,
yeah,
maybe then say,
all right.
And just say,
listen,
I'm not going to get mad if you start dating somebody else or something like
that.
And then you fucking get it out there and then he can fucking crush it in eighth
grade.
You're in that dude.
You're right.
A Uri taken down.
I'm in ninth grade.
This is like,
you're going from majors down to fucking college ball,
you know,
hang in,
curve balls all day long,
sending them into the fucking trees.
Like the thrill ride.
I mean,
one of the first thrill ride fucking video I sent,
Ya know.
All right.
All right,
Bill.
I'm an old girlfriend.
My old girl,
I'm old girlfriend wants baby.
Uh,
hey Billy,
I'm about to turn 48 and updating a great girl and she's just turned 34.
Lucky me.
I was pretty loosey and married for 26 years and never had children.
She has no baggage whatsoever.
No kids,
no x,
loser,
husband,
et Cetera.
Uh,
she said she would like to have at least one kid and I think she feels time is
running out.
I kind of think I am,
I'm too old,
but I don't want to lose her.
I like kids,
but they seem like a lot of work.
Oh,
those kids,
you know,
it seemed like a lot of work said,
seemed like a lot of work.
Even if completely healthy Jesus Christ.
Dude,
even more,
if they have any issues,
Jesus,
dude,
I can then,
you know,
you're one of those guys that shouldn't have had kids.
Not sure I got the energy for that.
I want to travel and go to shows and drink and continue to be selfish,
but in some way it sounds kind of cool.
Please help.
Maybe Nia has a take a p s Stewart Copeland is the greatest drummer of all time
capital and you know,
it's true.
Uh,
yeah,
he's one of the greats and if that's your greatest drum of all time,
I wouldn't argue that,
you know,
to each his own.
Um,
hey dude,
if you want to do it,
go ahead and do it.
I don't think it's a world,
you know,
and I think it's really like as far as like the work,
it's,
it's the first,
I think three,
four years.
Once they get around five and they kind of know right from wrong,
then you kinda got a buddy,
he's still going to be a pain in the ass,
but you know,
he's going to the bathroom himself,
you know,
or herself or whatever.
They kind of know right from wrong and then they think you're a god.
So like the next fucking seven years,
even though there's still going to throw temper tantrums of shit by the time to
seven or eight,
I mean,
yet if you did the fucking job and you're raised him,
right,
you gotta have a pretty cool kid and then,
uh,
you know,
enjoy the next five years because then once they become teenagers,
they think they fucking know everything and just pray to God.
They don't get knocked up or knock somebody up.
I get addicted to drugs.
It's really,
once they turn 13,
you just trying to get them through education,
getting a good job and not marrying a fucking psycho.
And if you do that,
then I think then you can finally fucking breathe a little bit.
That's what it seems like.
But um,
yeah,
it's a lot of work,
but there's a part of you that wants to do it.
So if you want to do it,
I would say do it now.
It's no,
never.
All right.
X Lady called me up.
Hey Billy bitch.
Tits a easy.
Jesus Christ.
I hope your meeting,
your weight loss goals.
I love listening to your podcast at the gym,
Yada,
Yada.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Oh,
speaking of drum,
and by the way,
I did the Goddamn comedy jam three times last week.
I got to play up live in a club now.
What a fucking,
what a thrill that is.
What a fucking thrill.
You know,
I want to thank Josh,
Adam Meyers and everybody,
uh,
in the band,
Joel,
Jay and nick for putting up with me and my awful fucking playing.
Um,
I was actually totally relaxed the whole week when I was playing,
you know,
I fucked up a lot,
but,
uh,
I just kept going.
I didn't drop time too much,
you know,
I don't think I,
I fucked up Phil's,
there's a couple,
you know,
double hits and the bass drum that I would like sounded like mud,
but whatever snare was right there on the toured four,
nobody noticed.
Um,
but what a fucking great time that is.
I can't imagine traveling with three other people and being in a band and being
fucking broke.
But I,
I can tell you right now,
sitting behind a set of drums,
you know,
best seat in the fucking house,
watching everybody else in the band going fucking nuts and actually see and
people like into it is,
is one of the fucking coolest things I've ever got to do.
So,
uh,
I'll be doing a lot more of those in the future.
Why the fuck not that fun is hell.
Anyways,
I love listening to your podcast at the gym,
Yada Yada,
Yada.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I need some advice about this x lady.
I used to date a few years back at the end of college.
She recently sent me a message wanting to hang out.
I asked her about a situation or a situation from a friend.
The lady is moving in in seven weeks and uh,
and quit her job.
Wait a minute,
I just started daydream and halfway through that I was thinking about drumming.
Isn't that weird?
You can actually do that.
Well,
somebody else keeps reading and talking.
All right.
I need some advice about this.
Actually I stayed a few years back.
She recently sent me a message wanting to hang out as four to six situated for
the lady is moving in seven,
seven weeks and quit her job.
I figured she was looking for a quick fling before she left.
Ah,
Bill,
I thought I had struck gold.
I really did one and a half months of no strings attached fun and then she would
just be fucking gone.
You idiot.
You probably saw too much and now she thinks is a reason to stay.
Never have to see you again.
Anyways,
I agree to hang out with her and that's when she tells me that she is homeless.
Ah,
Jesus Christ,
she's homeless.
How the fuck is she calling you?
She fucked up or lease and is out seven weeks before she leaves.
So now I'm hanging out with her in one week.
My question for you parentheses and maybe a wife could help,
uh,
add some female charm to the answer.
How do I bang her?
Oh my God,
but not have to let her live with me for two months.
You know what?
I got to put down the mic for half a second and just applaud you for admitting
to the exact selfish piece of shit thing that you want to do.
Hang on a second.
Got To love honesty.
Even if you don't like the what somebody wants to do,
I think she,
I should probably just go for it and worry about that situation later.
What do you thank you and please go fuck yourself.
A redheaded dope like yourself.
All right,
my freckles in arms here.
Um,
yeah.
All right.
How do I bang her but not have to live with her?
Oh,
simple.
You just put her up in a motel and you say you're going to pay for it.
That's what I would do as fucking filthy man.
Jesus Christ put up in a fucking hotel.
It'd be cheap.
She's not fucking homeless.
She'll feel obligated to Banga you've already banging before.
Won't feel so filthy and that's what you could do.
I might need a shower after this fucking answer,
but that I would just say that that's the way to go.
By no means letter ever.
Stay over at your house.
Do not ever fuck over at your house fucker at the motel that you put her up in.
That's what you need to do.
Okay?
She can not come over your fucking house if she asks you.
Why?
Just say,
just be honest.
Okay?
Just be honest.
Just say,
cause I'm not.
You know what dude?
Um,
yeah,
this is really fucked up.
She's calling you in a time of need.
She's gone it cause she's homeless ladies moving a seven weeks and quit her job.
Uh,
dude,
she might be on drugs.
She fucked up or least she's moving at.
I Dunno dude.
I Dunno man.
You might be fucking a somebody who's a using needles here,
man.
You know what I say,
dude,
I got one for you.
Why don't you fucking rub one out and then think about it.
Oh,
he says,
ps,
when is your next special coming out?
I think I speak for everyone when I say I can't wait to see it.
Well that's very nice.
Um,
well I put them out every two years.
So I came out,
the last one came out in December.
Every little more than two years.
So this is my year off where I just get the fuck around and have a great time,
which I'm doing and I'm,
I'm already,
you know,
I have some ideas about where I want to shoot my next one,
what I want it to look like,
and I'm just waiting for the material to come.
But,
uh,
I'm really,
I'm really happy.
I'll tell you I'm real.
I'll tell you,
I'm really happy with where my act was this past weekend when I was up in
Montreal.
Uh,
all right,
let me read the rest of this,
the rest of the,
uh,
advertising here,
and then I got a dilemma and a couple of overrated,
underrated.
Remember those?
All right,
where are we?
stamps.com everybody,
you know that feeling you get when the,
uh,
when you can get things done with just a click of your mouse.
It can't get more convenient than that.
And now you can even get your mailing and shipping done.
Sorry.
Get the hic hiccups here without leaving your desk.
Thanks to stamps.com oh God,
I got the hiccups.
Stick stamps.com churns your PC or Mac into your own personal post office that
never closes.
Talk about convenient buy and print official us postage for any letter or
package using your computer and printer.
Then just hand your mail to the mailman or drop it in the mailbox and you'll
never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my tour posters.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to do it.
So can you right now use my last name,
birth for this special offer?
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer.
How has this special you offer this for years,
every month?
Why can't we just say this wonderful,
awful offer includes a digital scale calc?
Well,
maybe cause they do it every month that makes it special.
Includes a digital scale,
calculates exact postage for letters and packages,
and up to $55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter
burr.
And finally,
legal zoom.
Uh,
do you want the government to decide what happens to your property or minor
children?
Jesus.
This swinging for the fences right out of the gate.
Grabbing your attention.
If not,
make the commitment to protect your family with the last will or living trust
today.
You got to do it.
It's national.
Make a will month@legalzoom.com and doing the right thing has never been easier.
They've created a better way for you and your spouse to take control of your
family's future.
Checkout legal zooms,
new last will and living trust bundles.
The more you plan ahead with wills,
trusts,
and powers of attorney,
the more you save.
Even if you're confused about all the options,
don't let that hold you back.
You can use their online resources and a state planning to a tool to help you
figure out what you need or get more specific guidance from legalzoom's network
of independent attorneys in most states since they're not a law.
Since then,
I'll offer don't procrastinate when it comes to protecting your family.
Get legal help.
You can count on@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter bur bur are in the referral box at checkout to save even
more.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code burr legal zoom.com and as always,
if you guys want to donate to the podcast,
I'm a cheap free way to do it is you just go to,
if you're going to go buy something at Amazon,
mmm.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com click on the podcast page,
click on the Amazon link.
It just takes you there.
And I just get credit for driving traffic there.
And uh,
they kicked me a portion of the proceeds and a percentage of those proceeds.
I sent it the Saint Jude's children's hospital because that seems to be like an
open up charity.
All right,
there you go.
Alright.
Dilemma.
Yeah.
Would you rather do a show with no swearing or take a bath with Oprah also with
no swearing.
Uh,
I wouldn't subject Oprah to taking a bath with me.
I do a show,
not swearing.
I've done that.
I could do that.
MMM.
Underrated.
Overrated.
These are from me,
underrated.
Calling it a night.
That's what I learned when I was in Montreal when I wasn't drinking and I was
just sitting there slam and waters and everything.
It got to that fucking point.
Like,
you know what?
There's a point where you saw everything that's going to happen.
Everything else is just going to get messy.
Get home now where you can still wake up early and fucking workout.
Uh,
also underrated drinking water's while everyone else is getting fucked up.
It's tremendous.
Everybody starts slurring.
They say crazy shit to you and right as they're getting just completely not even
tolerable,
you just fucking walk out and they don't even notice.
I'm also underrated working out in the morning.
Yeah.
Stepping on the scale after pushing a buck 90 a month ago and seeing one 81
eight 0.0.
All right.
Overrated after parties rich food and buying new shit.
You buy new shit and then it gets with your old shit.
Next thing you know,
you're fucking Romas,
Phil.
It's filled up.
You know what I mean?
You gotta get underrated.
Getting rid of shit.
I got stuff in my garage.
I have old DVDs.
Would you guys still buy DVDs?
If I put them up on my website?
A lot of graph,
all of them just to get them out of my garage.
I'm going to do it.
I think there's a few older people out there listening to the podcasts that are
old school like me and they want,
you know,
they want the gold behind their money.
They don't want to digitally own it.
They want to have the hard copy.
Um,
all right,
that's going to be the podcast for this week.
Uh,
what a week I had,
man,
Montreal,
Ottawa.
You guys were unbelievable.
Such great fans up there.
A goddamn comedy jam.
Josh,
Joel,
Jay and nick.
Thank you guys for putting up with my drumming and a thank you to everybody that
came out to my shows.
Um,
what else?
What else?
Who else did I want to thank God dammit.
I can't fucking remember.
Anyways,
I'm the worst.
I gotta stay,
you know I did.
All right.
This week I actually made some list.
Anyways,
this is going to take me forever to upload because my Internet sucks.
So I got an hour and 10 minutes here.
Guys.
Have a good weekend on Thursday.
I'll check in on you there.
All right,
go fuck yourself.
I'll talk to you later.